estos fanáticos no son argentinos
Residen en un territorio a miles de
kilómetros del hogar de la albiceleste
bangladesh su afición por el equipo
suramericano y Lionel Messi es
inigualable incluso por decantación
[Aplausos]
soy básicamente una fanática de Brasil
pero hoy rece para que Argentina ganara
el partido al menos por Messi porque es
la última copa del mundo de Messi
otros otorgan El Triunfo a una ayuda más
allá
me siento muy emocionada de que
Argentina gane por la gracia de alá eso
es todo las mismas emociones se
reflejaron en Pakistán a pesar de que su
equipo no hizo parte de la copa del
mundo los pakistaníes volcaron todas sus
esperanzas en el Astro argentino
somos hinchas de Messi y somos hinchas
de Argentina vinimos aquí con la
esperanza de que Argentina ganara el
Campeonato
queríamos que Messi consiguiera el
mundial ya que su último partido él
cumplió nuestra esperanza amo a Messi
un factor común unió a todos el último
partido de Lionel Messi con su equipo
nacional sin embargo el jugador descartó
esa hipótesis no me retiro de la
selección quiero continuar jugando para
Argentina para honrar el título de
campeón del mundo es el título que me
faltaba y aquí está es una locura ha
habido que esperar mucho estas
multitudes de apoyo al 10 argentino
confirman que no solo obtuvo el
campeonato mundial sino que también ganó
el corazón de millones en los rincones
más apartados